so I want to talk about one of the major
hidden reasons for hair loss okay check
this out this is very interesting I
don't know if you've ever heard of item
an H but another name for vitamin H is
biotin okay
now when you're deficient in biotin
you're gonna develop hair loss
especially alopecia okay number two you
may get thinning of the hair there were
three brittle nails or a skin rash could
be flaking scaly skin you could have a
loss of hair color mild depression
muscle pain or extreme tiredness but
other than that you're gonna be doing
great I'm being sarcastic
biotin acts as a cofactor a helper B
vitamin it's a type of B vitamin for
certain enzymes especially for the hair
and the skin and also to make certain
essential fats within body tissue and
that's all really interesting but what's
really important is to know why you
might be deficient and biotin so the
question is maybe you're not consuming
enough biotin from the diet right well
chances are that's not the reason
because it's in a lot of different foods
it's in almonds eggs onions tomatoes
peanuts salmon romaine lettuce
cauliflower and it's in a lot of other
foods as well or it may be you're
consuming too many raw eggs when you
consume raw eggs I'm talking about the
white part okay it has a certain
chemical that blocks your absorption of
biotin but you would have to consume at
least six to eight raw eggs every single
day for several months to have that
happen but the major reason why most
people are deficient in biotin are
either they don't have enough intestinal
good bacteria because we depend on our
good bacteria to make certain nutrients
especially biotin so if you took
antibiotics for some reason and is
destroyed your friendly bacteria and you
did
replace it that could be one reason why
you're not making biotin okay and when
you don't have the friendly bacteria you
get an overgrowth of an unfriendly
bacteria and that could lead to alopecia
right there so that's one cause the
other cause is malabsorption you don't
have the ability to absorb biotin in
your small intestine and that could be
coming from irritable bowel syndrome
celiac crohn's disease some type of
ongoing inflammatory condition that gave
you scar tissue and now you can't absorb
it and that would also explain why
someone would start taking a biotin
supplement and all of a sudden their
hair comes back their skin looks great
they start developing thicker hair and
their diets pretty good the problem is
they can't absorb 100% of it because
they have damage in their GI tract so
they have to take more to create the
effect or it could be that they have an
imbalance of microflora that they're not
able to make enough of it so they just
need a lot more so if you're having hair
loss and you've tried a lot of different
things you tried trace minerals you're
eating higher-quality protein you're
taking the B vitamins well guess what it
could be this right here so you may need
to take a supplement or you may need to
support your your friendly bacteria and
start taking more probiotics and if you
have not seen my other videos and hair
loss I put them up right here check them
out